I think that's kind of been hard for me
as it has kind of been not the most
amicable breakup and that's been tough I
wish it could be and I hope that it can
be you know for me I can get kind of
close that chapter and I'm moving on
from it
so bachelors star Amanda Stanton is
setting the record straight on what's
really going on with ex-fiance a Josh
Murray there's reports out there that
he's trying to win you back yeah it is
he like are you in communication okay so
it's funny they literally have no idea
who these sources are like where they're
getting their information from no I mean
you know we broke up back in December
seen each other a couple times I think
that's just kind of found to happen when
you're both a part of the bachelor
family but no you know I feel like
there's we're not going to get back
together he's not trying to get back
with me I'm not trying to get back with
him I think we've both moved on so okay
it's false are you looking to date I
mean I'm not like actively trying to
find somebody okay but I feel like you
know this year I've kind of taken some
time off just to like travel and focus
on me and focus on the kids and if
someone comes along then I'd be great so
what about bachelor in paradise I mean I
really did that and yeah
I gave it a try and it's like I know
that the process does work if you would
have asked me this like two months ago I
would have said no way there's no way
that I'm going back and like in the last
two months I'm like maybe maybe I could
see myself going back
are there any contestants that you would
be excited to meet like maybe if they
were going to be on the show hmm um no
any note like last year I didn't talk to
anybody before the show I met everybody
for the first time on the show besides
Nick I think that was a good way to go I
think you kind of get to know everybody
um I've only seen one episode of Rachel
season and I'm assuming that would
delete a majority of the guys so no I'd
be excited to me everybody if I'll get
back to you
all right I'm when I'm crushing on what
about bachelor games I still know did I
heard it's like winter games okay and
I'm like not a cold-weather person and
I'm not very athletic so I just don't
think it'd be a good fit for me
[Music]
you